good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday hope everyone's
having a blessed blessed day hey Jax
I'm doing good thank you so much excited
that it's Thursday as we descend into
the weekend Madness we prepare for
landing seat backs up and trade tables
store turdy Lou stowed
I they could be stored as well
you could store them away in this term
you know I'm kind of like really good
friends with the Points Guy the proper
term is stowed okay well you could Stow
how about we Stow you
[__] how about we show the turd
somebody woke up a little fiery today no
not at all I woke up extremely relaxed
you did a lovely morning I'm looking
gorgeous today you are so really no
complaints I got a new sweater
big big times and you know I love my
sweatshirts so I'm feeling good I'm so
glad how is uh how's the belly belly's
good belly is bellying belly's gonna
belly I can't say belly now without
thinking of that movie
the Summers I turned pretty the TV show
yeah her name was belly that was uh plot
hole
it was a plot hole I mean it's from the
book and it's really a nickname that
could only be given to someone who's
naturally thin and who's never struggled
with body image or weight I don't think
a person like that really exists but
it's fiction so we suspend disbelief
yeah so other than that all good here
redheads dropped this morning so it
really has been a relaxing exciting
morning you know our passions bearing
fruit everyone getting to listen to the
episode it's such a great episode
because it's a crazy good book that is
billed as a great book for book clubs
and you're probably like what does that
mean why like there's it's so ripe for
discussion like so many different
philosophical questions are asked love
that love that and even if you didn't
read the book or a knock if you're not
going to read the book like you could
still listen to the episode because the
premise I could sum up in one minute and
then it's a question of what would you
do la turd well I heard the redheads hit
70k on Instagram which is like kind of
like a really big deal I know it really
really is like we are just
growing growing growing
and it's really been so organic I was
saying on the show like it's not like
we've had a viral redheads moment like
oh my God those crazy redheads
um
Word of Mouth good hard work consistency
yeah you the redheads are very
consistent it it pays off this was our
40th episode 40 bucks if you I actually
don't know if there's anyone who's read
all 40 books because I did a call out I
posted all 40 books recently because
they're on my bookshelf and I said how
many have you read and I aside from the
people who host the show I didn't see
anybody who were 40 for 40. wow it's a
challenge the redheads challenge hashtag
hashtag the redheads challenge yeah
first one to complete
gets a personalized video from all the
redheads so cute
sweepstakes Giveaway sweepstakes
giveaway okay but how do you prove that
you read them all
um you know what we have to go by the
honor System and we are an honor System
like there's never going to I don't want
to jinx anything but I don't think
there's gonna be treasonous activity
within the redheads Community like we're
just not that kind of community no but
you know what is that kind of community
Hampton South Carolina where the Murdoch
murders took place where no no you don't
have to take your things off but like
[__] it's happening right now Claudia
either or don't I'm not listening to you
because I have managed to evade every
single morsel of information about this
trial I think the jury is out right now
literally uh if they came with the
verdict I don't know yet like I I don't
know anything so I want to keep not
knowing just in case I decide to dive in
so if you would like to speak on it let
me know
so I could take my headphones off okay
I'm not gonna I'm gonna say just one
thing and I didn't even it's just full
of information
um I watched a trial yesterday and then
I watched um Nancy Grace
Nancy Grace has been like at the
Forefront of this trial she has like her
own show where like during lunch breaks
oh my God she is so funny like she could
sensationalize
anything right before they got back from
lunch she had literally a six person
panel they were talking at first like
about interesting stuff but you know the
lunch break is long and eventually you
run out of [__] to talk about she's
talking about how she was walking
through the back entrance and she saw
the bailiff bringing lunch to the jurors
and it was lasagna and carbs can make
people very tired middle of the day
that's a heavy lunch and what does that
mean for how the prosecution is going to
open back up after lunch and I was like
I honestly only respect for my queen
Nancy Grace like talk about
understanding your job like your job is
to talk your job is to look into
everything your job is to make things
interesting that might not be
interesting I.E lasagna and I just
wanted to say respect for what Nancy
Grace is doing out here I have respect
as well but like that is a suspiciously
heavy lunch lasagna is not a lunch Nancy
Grace thought so as well someone's
trying to tire out the jurors I think
she's on to something no the thing about
Nancy Grace is like she doesn't see
things the way we see things like me and
Nancy Grace could spend the day together
and then I would recount how the day
went and Nancy would recount how the day
went and you would be describing two
different days she's very perceptive
she is perspective but I would say your
perceptive to turdy but she also really
did like invent like the sensationalist
trial Vibe like you know ever since the
90s she's been like hunting down you
know murderers and her headline news
show she's kind of like an icon I feel
like people don't talk about her enough
and until you watch her like
except there was one thing that was
really bothering me and she I believe is
Southern so many people who are involved
in this are southern
um and to be honest like people don't
talk enough about the language Bearer
barrier between Southerners and
non-southerners because they kept saying
Gerards and I'm like what is Gerards and
then I was like I think they're saying
jurors I kind of like Gerards better you
know what because jurors is not a word
no totally but I was like what is a
Girard and everyone on the panel
everyone on the panel that she hosted
during the lunch break was Southern so
they all kept saying jurors I'm like is
that a person for the case who I'm not
familiar with I love that the rural
Gerard all of a sudden it's not such a
mouthful right right these are rural
Gerards no uh yeah well there are parts
of the town that are really rural like
Mozelle where the shooting took place
it's like a 2000 Acre Farm that's been
sold actually yeah I did know those
things that there was a farm there was a
shooting and it's been sold
um so thankfully you haven't spoiled
anything for me no this isn't a spoiler
either but I did just find out um
through our family chat our family chat
has been really lit up about this The
Daily Mail Center article Mozelle this
Farm that's like you know
belongs to the family and everyone in
the documentary was like you know it's
their Farm it's been in their farm for
years yada yada uh literally like
they've only owned it for like a little
while and it's a little while like a
couple of years and like before this
whole thing happened and they didn't
even buy it like somebody gave it to
them it was like a trade it was like
really shady that doesn't sound Shady
that sounds more
um
you don't just get a 2 000 Acre Farm
like in a deal I guess when you're
dealing with Shady people everything is
Shady but that kind of like I I've
actually heard of that happening where
like people like trade properties like
if you have no it was like for like a
thousand dollars like it was like a
really little amount and I feel like
okay maybe [__] like that happened a
hundred years ago and his family was in
the town a hundred years ago like a
crazy story my granddaddy lost to bed
and gave up you know like I could see
yeah yeah but not like eight years ago
you know oh that's interesting this just
a lot of interesting things uh yeah I
literally don't know anything I how many
episodes is the Netflix stock three just
watch it and they're all under an hour
when she Lou I've been so busy this week
I think this is like my eighth podcast
of the week I not only had to record the
redheads I had to edit the redheads
which you know I take very personally so
you're just not prioritizing the toast
noted yeah no this week the toast has
fallen by the wayside I didn't give it
off I didn't give it all to the patreon
this week I didn't give it all to the
show you're right turdy Lou
you're right
the characters in The Martin yeah I'm
trying to say why don't you go down to
the courthouse say hi y'all I'm turdy
Lou no literally everyone has like a
really Southern name like Reggie like
they all have like really long like row
row
Papa they all have um
you are turtle Murdoch even though even
though I literally been is that their
name Murdoch like Richard spelled Rupert
okay so it's spelled
m-u-r-d-o-u-g-h no it's technically I
get it it's technically murder everyone
in the documentary said Murdoch like
literally Richard Rupert that's just the
same thing I did the same thing Rupert's
family but it's spelled differently and
it's murder
turdy Lou murder here service yeah I'm
here to testify I swear to tell the
whole truth nothing but the truth so
help me God I'm a distant cousin of the
murders and I saw some things I did see
something and I would love to talk to
them Gerards so I've been watching the
trial and I haven't watched like a lot
of Trials but I did watch the Johnny
Depp one
um and the actual courtroom is so
different this one is so small and like
there's so many people in it and they're
sitting on these wooden church pews like
for hours on end oh my God I don't know
who would volunteer to go sit there it
looks so like I would get actually a
sciatica you need a heating pad well
they don't show the jury because they
have to protect their their um
identities but I do wonder what kind of
chairs the jury is sitting in because I
do think that would make an impact on my
decision because
yeah if I'm sitting on a wooden chair
with like no cushion and I can't bring
my own heating pad like I'm out
yeah I'm out I'm angry I'm volatile and
that's gonna affect my decision in that
room
but in which way
I'm gonna be pissed and I'm just going
to want to get there no I'm I'm going to
be wanting to get this over with so I'm
going to make the decision that I feel
like is gonna move the conversation like
majority probably and that's why you
wouldn't be a good drawer no and I feel
like I've said this many times and if I
ever do get picked for a jury like this
will come back to to hopefully save me
do not pick me for a jury like I'm
extremely emotional I'm extremely biased
I really don't like I have preconceived
notions of people I'm very judgmental
and I usually let those judgments Carry
Me Through I'm usually right but I'm
just saying don't [__] pick my ass as
a jury even though like being picked on
a jury like this while it is torture
because it's you know months and weeks
on end you
the the opportunities that come your way
books interviews podcasts money it's
kind of worth it yeah but charity I
don't want to you know destroy the
narrative you've built of yourself as a
horrible juror but you also always see
both sides I do I do
it might be an ideal juror oh but like
I'm also a curious little cat that you
can't you can't watch anything you can't
talk to people you can't watch documents
I would actually be the perfect Gerard
for this trial I don't know anything you
would be the perfect Gerard I I do
wonder I'm sure they weren't allowed to
but like if there's a juror who's
watched one of the documentaries or saw
the tick tocks like they're in in the OJ
case like they were all locked in hotel
rooms because it was so National
um they had no TVs no phones no
magazines
it was literally hell um but I think
these people go home every night like
how can you really trust 15 of your
peers not to just like look at
something it's an honor System and yeah
it's been that way for hundreds of years
so you have to have faith in people yeah
you do and I don't so that's another
reason why I shouldn't be a good juror
and it's also like
this was a small town that this happened
in right
yeah very and this is a very big thing I
think they want to get it right like for
their town for their people because if
if they don't then then a murderer is on
the loose right if it's not big man
murdagh yeah I don't know his name Alec
well that's the other thing it's a-l-e-x
and they call him Alec and they actually
don't even say Alec they say Alec
um I find like the names in this trial
to be the most infuriating part like
Alex murdaugh is how it's spelled and
everyone's like Alec Murdock
okay it's so annoying
good to know
so just like start for real like let's
go
okay I'm trying to talk
I will maybe today
maybe today
well
that's all I got oh I finished the Lucy
score sequel like the highly anticipated
sequel to her breakout book things we
never got over the sequel came out like
a week ago oh my God what a bad book I
was shocked like first of all I
not that you know we know it wasn't the
character he wanted to read about it
wasn't but like eventually I feel like
with sequels it never is and then
because I'm so used to like the people I
got used to in the first book but then
after like 10 I'm like you you they
really do make you like them actually I
ended up really liking both characters
um but my God like so cliche so
unoriginal and no sex like come on
that's what we opened these books for
like not to be a freak but like let's
just not for the plot let's just be
honest
story right so it just it I gave it a
two out of five and that felt generous
it was really and it was long it was
just no bueno okay well thank you for
the review oh also should we tell
everyone how this might be like our last
show because we're going to be able to
retire soon
sure
Jackie's banking Jackie thinks we're
gonna retire this week
for Private Island
because I posted a link to my new fruit
bowl and I've never and I post oh the
reason why we get to retire is because
um it's an affiliate link but the
affiliate link system that I usually use
doesn't have William Sonoma so I said
turdies is the one that you use have
William Sonoma and it did so it's
turny's affiliate link on my page so I'm
getting paid so Jackie's hard work we're
splitting you know whatever comes our
way but like literally we are not
splitting but like oh we can both retire
no for sure the plan was that you were
gonna take the money and then buy my
next fruit bowl then link again and we
could just keep buying fruits right it's
just like a free fruit bowls for
everyone
so I literally got so many clicks all
night I was updating Claudia with the
click town and like I think we can
retire soon once the numbers come in
you're gonna start calling me Richard
because I'm retired return ya returnia I
could see you being retired except like
Sam the irrelevance I know it's my
biggest fear yeah no I like what at this
I'll do this still but like maybe even
when you're retired
but well that wouldn't be retired but
it's like even if we could retire from
the fruit bowl sales
I would rather just like get a second
home you know yeah of course of course
no I don't want to retire I'm too young
I'm too sprightly I've got too much
energy and that's to say I genuinely
enjoy this so me too me too I think I
would be sad if I were tired I would
miss this so instead like maybe we'll
get like a house in Aspen with our fruit
bowl sales oh wow okay yeah I think you
need to sell a few more but sure okay
well um I'll post another link
um totally separate tangent but you're
just reminding me of something so Ben is
still gone I'm still alone and literally
being alone is my worst nightmare like
I've been feeling my days that's why
I've been reading like I've been really
trying to like not get myself to a
position where I'm reminded of how alone
I am
um
but you know I took like kind of a turn
yesterday where I'm like starting to
enjoy it like I don't know like it's
kind of a Vibe first of all my house is
so [__] clean it's like when I
have a dish I just wash it when I put
something away like it's either dirty or
clean like it's been so easy to keep my
house clean I've kind of been like
loving it I can play whatever music I
want I don't have somebody yapping in my
ear about my reading and I don't know
I'm kind of telling Ben I'm like yeah
maybe you should stay yeah out of sight
out of mind I'm kind of kind of like an
independent woman I love that for you
turd yeah I feel like like a character
in Sex in the City honestly yeah no
being alone I've always enjoyed it and
especially when it like means that it's
like your space and especially in the
apartment like it's all yours yeah if
you want to hang on the couch do you
want to hang in the bedroom you want to
go back and forth you want to play music
throughout the whole place not have to
worry about someone's calls someone's
calls and I'm married to like the king
of calling oh my God I can't stand calls
in my house I'm like get out with your
toxic call energy no Ben is always on
calls I'm like I'm understanding like
he's running a business of course work
day calls I'll always allow uh but he
goes out of his way to like make more
calls like a text no I'll call them and
then it turns into like a 25 minute
conversation always with the calls in
the car oh my God it's infuriating the
calls the sound of his voice has made me
want to seriously rip out my hair oh
that's not good I know so I've just been
enjoying my alone time I want to update
everyone it's good and how are your
cooking Adventures going oh [__] that
[__] I give up you should try following
a recipe sometime nah I had a bowl of
cereal last night
you should do like home Chef because it
literally like has pictures directions
it's idiot proof it's dirty proof it is
I've done it before one of those
services like it's definitely idiot
proof
um but it just requires planning and
that's you know I'll send you my promo
code
so you could retire so I could get
another house
um well I'm ready to dive in are you I
am ready turdy Lou without further Ado
About turreted Lube here are the best I
have stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
legacybox every day your home movies and
photos are slowly fading away they fade
away in closets or worse they break down
because of the dampness of your garage
the heat in your attic but digitizing
your old media with Legacy box stops The
Fading and allows you to preserve those
recorded moments so they're safe forever
you can join the over 1 million families
that have trusted Legacy box to digitize
their memories today we had all of our
we grew up in the VHS era all of our old
like tapes sitting in a box underground
in our like basement Cellar
um and when we finally did Legacy box I
have to tell you it was such a joy like
it was exciting to like send it in and
finally feel that weight off your
shoulders and then get some space back
in your uh in your storage unit but they
would send us updates throughout the
process then we all got together to
watch and it was so cute like it was so
cute VHS recordings of like the four of
us performing Spice Girls and our dad
was in there was like so nice to get a
piece of that back and also my favorite
thing about watching old Home Videos is
realizing how we are all the same yeah
as we were then like Olivia bossing us
around 100 you being like Diva the most
yeah always me having your back
I'm a snitch of the little baby just
following her big sisters that part that
that part changed that part changed
Legacy box is the easiest and safest way
to preserve your family's memories it is
uh simply the best way to preserve your
past it's simple it's safe they thought
of everything for bringing your memories
into the 21st century
trusted by over a million families it's
easy and safe for a limited time only
you can visit legacybox.com toast and
save 50 that's legacybox.com toast to
shop 50 off while the sale won't last
long make sure you go to legacybox.com
toast now to you know get your memories
back Take Back Control girly take back
your memories
our first story you're gonna have to go
back down memory lane to Monday night
when we met Josh popper the summer house
boxing coach who was yeah reportedly
dating Madonna yep Madonna is reportedly
dating her hunky boxing coach whose 35
years her Junior irrelevant what's
relevant is that his name is Josh popper
and you might recognize him from Monday
night's episode of summer house because
he was flirting with Sam he's Sam's
boxing coach they almost hooked up but
he didn't and now I guess he's dating
Madonna by the way 35 [__] that is a lot
of years sources told the Daily Mail on
Wednesday that Josh has been training
one of Madonna's six children at his gym
Breadwinners in New York City uh days
after revealing her new face at the
quote new face I think she posted that
that it was a new face
um at the 2023 Grammy Awards the
hitmaker shared photos with her
suspected nubo via her Instagram story
in the since expired snaps the singer
could be seen cuddling up to her heavily
tattooed sparring partner owner while
pressing her lips against his shoulder
and squeezing his bulging bicep
this is gross for a million reasons
mostly because she's 35 years older than
him and this is so inappropriate and
disgusting
um I kind of like don't like Madonna and
she hasn't really made it easy
especially because like last time he
spoke about her like I wasn't really
alive for like the Madonna Glory years
so my really only experience as like an
adult with a functioning brain when it
comes to Madonna is like her being
thirsty and weird and like kind of gross
um and this is just adding to the list
of reasons why I'm on a [__] with
Madonna Like This is really disgusting
yeah it's exciting like for us who um I
wouldn't have cared about I literally
have would not have cared one iota about
Madonna's new Young boyfriend Not only
would it not be a story on the show but
like when I read the headline I wouldn't
even read it I would just like scroll
past it yeah but the fact that we he was
just on summer house like what are the
odds it's not like Sunday two seasons
ago like literally three days ago makes
it titillating no it's a crazy bizarre
coincidence he must be a really good
boxing coach like all of his customers
just falling in love with him so true I
mean he's very handsome and we said he
had really good energy Claudia was even
saying he should be on summer house well
now he certainly should yeah I mean they
definitely need uh do you think some
guys do you think Madonna should be on
summer house I think she wouldn't say no
and that's the problem currently with
Madonna agreed
I wish her the best honestly this is
extremely bizarre behavior extremely
inappropriate
um how old is he he is 30
29 and she is 64.
that's [__] gross
that is disgusting
yes
and imagine if the genders were reversed
imagine
uh I don't subscribe unlike unfollow
gross bye yep are you ready for our next
story which we do subscribe we do follow
we do say hello because sassy Schroeder
is pregnant expecting her second baby
with her husband Bo and we can add
another one to the pregnancy crew for
2023. it's shaping up to be a great year
I was so happy when I heard this like
this is so nice and I read her book um
where she talked about her first
pregnancy and her first pregnancy was
like really during a hard time first she
wasn't really sharing on social media
because she had just gotten fired from
the show
um she didn't even get to announce her
pregnancy like somebody who knows her
leaked it and she said in the book she
didn't know who it was but like that
moment was stolen from her
um so for her to be able to do this like
on her own time and share her own photos
and like document the journey with her
podcast like that's really if I feel
like for her probably feels like a lot
of this these are first time things yeah
when I did her podcast we were both not
pregnant
it was in like September or October we
were talking about like you know she was
talking about how she had a hard
pregnancy and how like she wasn't
looking for like because it was like
that it was also because of covid that
it was very like isolating that it was
like making her not looking forward to
doing it again but I was like no now I'm
looking forward to doing all the things
that we couldn't do the first time like
even just like
wearing a bathing suit I never wore a
bathing suit in
when I was pregnant with Harry just
because I didn't go anywhere nowhere to
go yeah yeah so I hope that like now we
can both like enjoy all the things that
we couldn't in the first like
restaurants and you know if there's a
wedding now experiences yeah experiences
and not just being like in confinement
right which is hard enough but as a
pregnant person can I'm sure be like
really toxic yeah so I'm I'm so happy
for her um me too and it's shaping up to
be a great crew also I forgot to mention
on patreon Brianna yeah who's the
pregnant crew now
Rihanna stassi me Raven Gates Emily
didonato
Jackie Schimmel Jackie Schimmel
um
who was I just about to say oh Whitney
Carson from Dancing With the Stars okay
random I follow her I like she's really
so cute
um
it's a good girl it's a good crew and
then a bunch of people just had babies
so it's like I was following them when I
was in my first trimester but like and
they were in there last we were
technically pregnant together but only I
knew uh and also like let's see what
else there who else
right it's still early it's still early
the crew could the crew could grow yeah
I feel like they're I'm also only
talking about influencers really yeah
but I feel like there are celebrities
that we've announced recently are
pregnant hmm
Sophia Grace
oh that's huge for the group
huge for the group huge that's [__]
crazy oh my God
wow this list is so Random
Oh Katie Stevens from the Bold type
how nice how nice
Ryan lochte's wife love oh my God throw
back to Ryan Lochte living Lochte
remember that no it wasn't called living
Lochte it was living Lohan that was the
other issue I really had a reality show
yeah that was weird that was Rumor
Willis
right let's go back to Ryan Lochte Ryan
Lochte was was and is so hot yeah for
sure and so talented such a hard worker
good swimmer yeah good swimmer but then
he did that weird thing yeah I forget
the details but he did something weird
he was also like he was a bad boy he was
a bad boy but like he was always being
compared to Michael Phelps and Michael
Phelps had the what was his scandal he
smoked vodka yeah like oh who [__]
cares but like Ryan lochte's Scandal was
like kind of way worse he like
he
behaved badly at a night out in the
Olympics right no no he went to a gas
station and like
let me just Google it because I feel
like what's up in Rio in Rio it was
Ryan Lochte gas station oh so Jessie J
is pregnant
oh yeah that's also really nice I'm so
happy for her yeah me too okay so Ryan
and a bunch of other swimmers claimed
that they were robbed Sunday morning
while leaving a party in a taxi
um and they were claiming they were
robbed by people posing as police
officers but the story varied depending
on who was telling it and at one point
Ryan locked he said a gun was held to
his head but later he said the gun was
merely pointed in his Direction he also
initially claimed that his taxi had been
pulled over only to later say that the
robbery had occurred at a gas station
did any of that happen
video footage captured over the course
of the night shows the swimmers in
various places security camera footage
shows the swimmers entering and exiting
the gas station and then leaving in a
taxi later security footage shows the
swimmers going through her security uh
going through security to enter the
Olympic Village a Brazilian judge who
ordered that the swimmers remain in Rio
noted that the group looked surprisingly
calm given their claim that they had
been robbed at gunpoint
oh I think it was like something like
they were getting back late and they
were gonna get in trouble and they were
like drunk and they shouldn't have been
so they like came up with this crazy
story yeah but then like they were like
it became huge news while three American
Olympians in Rio were held up at
gunpoint we have to investigate right
but they were just like lying yeah that
like wasn't made into as big of a deal
as I remember like the Ryan Lochte pot
thing
Michael Phelps thank you
um
but just like throw back to the right
and Lochte era remember when he beat
Michael Phelps like that rivalry was
kind of everything so you know two
All-American swimmers I know but it
really like wasn't a rivalry because
Michael Phelps is just like better
the actual goat and Ryan Lochte is just
like a really really good swimmer yeah
and like Ryan Lochte was like a really
good swimmer like also a really hard
worker and like for like a few years
Michael Phelps went through this phase
where like he was like you know a star
and he was just like getting by on his
talent yeah he was coasting because he's
just like more genetically
gifted because he's gifted and like
something really sad was like the last
Olympics I watched like leading up to
the Olympics where the qualifiers like
Ryan Lochte didn't qualify and he tried
so like that was sad that was like Cody
Simpson yeah but Cody Simpson wasn't
already an Olympian so yeah
no but I mean he had his time it's not
sad what is in the Olympics like I'm
ready
next summer Paris oh my God a whole year
and a half 24. yeah
damn
I'm sorry dirty
I'm ready
did we just have a winter Olympics must
have it in 2020 oh yeah
no nobody watched it was member it was
last year uh I think it was in China
they like everything was like fake snow
it was like yeah the people didn't want
to support it was not the vibe it was
not the vibe it was actually really sad
for the Olympians who like I know no one
cared yeah yeah our next story is kind
of crazy
kind of crazy kind of crazy because
there's a new show coming out called the
idol that is um produced directed by the
creator of euphoria Sam Levinson and he
is being accused of ramping up the
sexual content and nudity of the
upcoming HBO drama the idol and twisting
it into a quote rape fantasy so the
Rolling Stone published a very damning
piece about this new show where 13
alleged members of the series cast and
crew spoke out over their discomfort
with the show's new creative Direction
quote it was like any rape fantasy that
any toxic man would have in the show and
then the woman comes back for more
because it makes her music better one
production member told the magazine of
Sam's version of this new show another
source added it was like what is this
what am I reading here it was like
sexual torture porn
however HBO told page six that they're
pleased with how production has unfolded
since Sam took over the Reigns of the
show quote the creators and the
producers of the idol have been working
hard to create one of the HBO's most
exciting and provocative original
programs this show Stars the weekend and
Lily Rose depth the concept is like the
weekend is like this Wellness Guru cult
leader and Lily Rose up is this Rising
pop star and I guess they have this like
[__] up exclusive relationship
um where he like but I this is just from
what I've read like when she keeps like
coming back from where I guess she
thinks it makes her the music better
it's like physically abusive I think
mentally just like when he just [__]
up [__] [__] up [__] anyway so the
Rolling Stone publishes like piece 13
people speaking out about what they saw
about things that were in the script
that actually never were shot but just
like [__] up script ideas okay then
the weekend posted deleted
um at Rolling Stone like did we make you
mad and he put in a clip from the show
where they [__] trash Rolling Stone
right they referenced so he was
basically saying your article doesn't
really have Merit because you're just
mad about what we what we said about you
said and it's like um that is a really
weird coincidence like did they see that
and then they were mad or is that just a
coincidence that the art I think it's I
think it's a coincidence and I have to
see the show and like see what they're
talking about
but there is something to be said about
this [__] freak Sam Levinson and I
think it gets really glazed over in
Euphoria because Euphoria is like
star-studded and everyone loves it but
it's really there are so many Euphoria
scenes that are so uncomfortable
especially through the lens when you're
thinking about these are like juniors in
high school
um and I know that they're technically
adults like it's all fine but like when
we're supposed to be watching the show
about high school teenagers there's
really [__] dark
sexual problematic [__] and this guy Sam
is definitely a [__] freak yeah
um and so I'm inclined to believe this
article like I really am me too I don't
watch Euphoria because I literally
watched a few minutes once and it
literally made me so like depressed
depressed like for just like the
children and the clips that I've seen in
like the story lines that like you talk
about in recap it's just like [__] up
unnecessary like gratuitous and sexual
and the idea that he's doing another
show that's like taking all that to the
next level and with like people who are
actually adults right it's believable I
believe that it's [__] up and
um is concerning I believe that I agree
too I'm more inclined to side with
rolling stone on this one and I don't
think like Rolling Stone as a whole
would like put together a piece with 13
Witnesses just because like some TV show
called them irrelevant you know yeah
also it's worth mentioning that TMZ
published a separate story on Wednesday
that called into question the validity
of Rolling Stone sources and claim that
none of the 13 people the magazine spoke
to had seen the final product of the
idol which well they weren't claiming
that they did this yeah they saw the
script and they could have seen bits and
pieces and not like the show from
beginning to end and had something to
say about it so they could be talking
about specific scenes and they could
also be talking about just like script
ideas and the set Vibes but it's also
worth mentioning Lily Rose stepp had
glowing things to say about Sam Levinson
she never felt so comfortable so
appreciated so this that so I don't know
I feel like a lot of the people that
work with him especially the young girls
like say that
um and I don't know I just like don't
like I have a a weird feeling like I
don't I just don't believe that it's all
hunky-dory I have a weird feeling she
said this quote Sam is for so many
reasons the best director I have ever
worked with never have I felt more
supported or respected in a creative
space my input and opinions more valued
working with Sam is a true collaboration
in every way it matters to him more than
anything not only what his actors think
about the work but how we feel
performing it
yeah okay that could also that could be
true but then you know there's also
something to say about what show the
show like Euphoria did for Alexa Demi
and Sydney Sweeney and not Zendaya
because she was popping off ready but
like everyone who was a part of it and I
think a lot of people see that and want
that so
I don't know maybe this is just me being
cynical because she's saying it's all
good but I'm just like not buying it
I think this guy is a freak and I think
like we all get so caught up in Euphoria
like I definitely feel weird watching it
like I really do yeah I think there's
there's inappropriateness going on and
and it's highly likely that he has taken
it way too far yeah and you know who I
really would love to hear from because I
feel like she's the only person who like
would say something is Barbie Ferreira
because she's not on the show anymore
she played Cat the first two seasons the
second season she was like barely in it
and there was like a lot of rumors that
her and Sam were like not vibing and she
was like mad about a lot of stuff that
was going down and then she left and
like that's it's the biggest show
you don't leave you know what I mean
yeah unless you're scrupled and like
you're you're you have a backbone and
you're mad about something
um I also I would love to hear from her
sometimes she doesn't want to get a
reputation for being like difficult to
work with whistleblower especially when
everyone has glowing things to say about
him right I feel like sometimes what can
happen is like someone who is like a
really big star even Lily Rose Depp like
has people in her corner is established
like she's not someone you [__] with
would [__] with or it could take
advantage of as easily as someone who is
needs to show brand new coming up
doesn't know the industry like no it's
so I feel like two different people on
the same show could have a different
experience like based on who they are no
you're right like I don't think anyone
would be dumb enough to [__] with Johnny
Depp's daughter no she's protected
you're 100 right and like and she's
worked for years she's Chanel girl like
yeah she has people and systems in place
that protect her and like it's not like
it's this show where nothing for her
yeah and you're right like Barbie
Ferreira started out as an influencer
yeah and worked her way up to the
[__] Met Gala but it's a different
background you're right
so yeah maybe Zendaya has had a great
experience with Sam because Sam wouldn't
dare right and you know Zendaya just it
came out she'll be negotiated her
contract she will be making a million
dollars an episode from Euphoria episode
wow good for her mm-hmm
which is so crazy because like
when I watch Euphoria I actually don't
like her Parts her parts are really the
dark part she's the one who struggles
with addiction and like mental health
um I like like the silly drama from high
school you stole my boyfriend Maddie Rue
when was this like that's a part of the
show that I'd like like the really dark
stuff I find to be really depressing and
while it's probably like a real for a
lot of people it honestly makes me
depressed yeah I think that's the Sam
Levinson stuff yeah no the Sam Levinson
stuff is like the very weird up close of
Sydney Sweeney's nipples and she's a
junior in high school like it's [__]
weird
are you ready for our next story if our
next story is brought to you bye
let me
introducing the bed by thuma handcrafted
from eco-friendly high quality upcycled
wood the bed has modern minimalist
design that helps you elevate any space
it's super supportive for your mattress
it's breathable and it's made to
naturally minimize noise and create
space Jax I know that you have the bed
by thuma up in your guest room that
we're calling snitches room tell me
about the experience of receiving the
bed putting the bed together and now
living with the bed the experience of
receiving the bed and putting them in
together was unlike any other Furniture
building experience that I've had before
it was seamless it was easy I could do
it with Zach and us not you know not
have to not talk to each other for the
rest of the day right it was very quick
it's just made to be assembled very
quickly the way that it's for like
manufactured is genius really really
genius and it's a gorgeous bed it's very
minimalist looking so you can make the
room whatever you want it to be I love
it
you can now customize the bed by
choosing between their original pillow
board and the new solid wood headboard
along with the bed thuma offers other
bedroom Essentials to elevate your
bedtime like the mattress the nightstand
the side table and they're all perfect
complements to the bed they also have
Finance financing options available on
the thermo website create that feeling
of checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma now go to thuma.co toast to
receive a 25 credit towards your
purchase of the bed plus free shipping
in the continental US go to thuma.co
toast that's t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash
toast for 25 credit
thank you Claudia you're welcome okay
our next story is news that I'm finding
so interesting and if you hate Royal
news and you hate talking about books
you're gonna [__] hate this story
okay and that makes me love it Sarah
Ferguson Duchess Fergie has written her
new romantic novel and apparently she's
an established author and she writes
historical fiction so she is turning the
page with her new novel a most
intriguing Lady Sarah whose title is the
Duchess of York tells people exclusively
in this week's issue about what inspired
her to incorporate a detective element
in her new historical fiction novel out
March 7. so this novel is literally
historical fiction it's a book that I
would read it's about the Duchess of
booklet who was one of Queen Victoria's
like closest Confidant she's even in the
show Victoria she's played by Diana Rigg
from Game of Thrones so she's like a
real
person it's about her youngest daughters
Lady Marion lady her daughters Lady Mary
and Lady Margaret because the Duchess of
York wants to write about invisible
women in history and that is very much a
trend you know people find like someone
who's didn't get the credit they deserve
and all of a sudden we're talking about
them so she is just like a historical
fiction girly author and I swear I would
see this book on my Goodreads and I
would read it and I would have no idea
that it was written by her I don't know
if she's like uh
like I don't know if I would I would
literally never in my life read this
book but like if I was debating it I
don't know if I could trust her to be
like so unbiased you know she's been in
the royal family she's seen it all she's
been excommunicated she literally was
exiled from the country I know well
she's actually admitting that she said
um not that she's not biased but that
the character Lady Mary in his book in
her book is her she said I believe that
lady Mary the real life heroine of her
new book she's so me and I really have
explored a whole different side of me
through Lady Mary and so now I don't
worry about someone saying oh are you
Lady Mary my answer is yes you know uh
she also has written a different
best-selling novel called her heart for
a compass where she again explores the
theme of invisible women
um and she talks about how she loves
historical romance she said I cry at
Hallmark you know just mentioning
Hallmark I could cry I love romance and
I love the beauty of love and joy and
Magic
Fergie Duchess Fergie is like kind of
having a moment in the last few years
she's really back in the Royal fold yeah
when she was like excommunicated for so
long why was she excommunicated because
she got divorced divorced the feet picks
yeah yeah Affairs
yeah I think the feet
yeah like some guy was sucking her toes
on the beach and Paparazzi caught it
yeah and it was like she's kind of
freaky and it was the 90s like now you'd
be like get your feet girl yeah get your
toes sucked and so she divorced him well
they got divorced all that stuff
and did you have to leave the country
I don't know I don't think so oh okay
because also your girls were there she
was in an episode of Friends like that
is how desperate she got at one point
wow she said quote I have been invisible
for my own self for a very long time now
and so now I'm just beginning to sort of
liberate and sort of test the waters
right so invisible women for me and a
voice from the grave is crucial for me
which is why I chose this period in
history because for example lady
Margaret and Lady Mary all their
brothers were written about but they
weren't so I think my real love is to
take on an invisible women woman from
the grave and say right this is your
story how would you like to be told and
just to tell it okay she also was quoted
speaking about the queen glowingly
recently and how she really looks up to
her that's sweet which is sweet yeah
she's having a moment I'm kind of living
for it right and it's got to stick
together let me see how many pages this
book is and if I would read it because I
feel like I would be more inclined to
read it if I didn't know that she wrote
it you know what I mean for sure like
it'd be a fun fact you found out
afterwards totally but it was like Cloud
368 Fair
okay I will not be reading it no but you
wouldn't this you wouldn't read the best
historical fiction book of the year I
actually read a historical fiction book
this year which one woman on fire oh
right and you loved it really good
really good really really good this is
called a most intriguing lady if you do
find yourself intrigued by the premise
which I do
and you she might have access to some
docs
and some actual historical factoids at
us lay people do not perhaps yeah
so do with that information what you
will today ladies and gentlemen
lettuce
are you a lady
uh
good question are you a most intriguing
lady no no no no no no but am I a lady
it depends who you ask and it depends
where I am in my home
no that's okay
but no I'm not a lady I'm not you are
thank you but I am not I would love to
be you're not a girl not yet a woman not
yet a lady
we'll never be a lady just attorney
I'm not a girl
I'm just a turdy
love that yeah our fifth and final story
um I don't even know what to call this
news it's good good news I guess is that
good news no no no not like that oh oh
not like like just like
people who have done wrong doing right
news oh I love that is it a Redemptive
story kind of because the Redemptive a
word yeah yeah okay Billy McFarlane the
fire Festival Creator is out of prison
he has been you know out and about he
went on Sofia with an F podcast and he's
teaming up with Andy King the guy he
asked to you know perform fellatio for
Evian water in the documentary
um again and now they're selling cheese
sandwiches for a good cause
remember the cheese sandwiches yeah yeah
yeah okay what's that cause the cause is
for the Bohemian workers who didn't get
paid
over fire Festival so fire Festival
Creator Billy McFarland is getting back
into the cheese sandwich game but don't
worry these won't come in styrofoam
while you're getting screwed out of a
concert in the Bahamas sources close to
Billy tell TMZ he recently had a reunion
for the first time in five years with
Andy King yes the guy who says Billy
asked him to give oral sex to a customs
officer to get shipments of Evian water
released seems all is well between them
now though because they shot a video
together promoting their newest Venture
selling grilled cheeses at seventh
Burger in New York City and the clip is
pretty funny the video features Andy
making the sandwiches a tongue-in-cheek
take on the ridiculous cheese on bread
meal served at the doomed Bahamas
Festival he's also taking swigs from
Evian water bottles TMZ has told that
100 of the sales from the April 7th
event will go to the workers in the
Bahamas where still owed money from
firefest they also tease a Coachella
trip in the video but we're told that
hasn't been set in stone yet
oh that's nice I mean when you brought
this up I was like ready to China like
I'm so done talking about [__] fire
Festival like it was so to me it's like
so
over and like played out all the jokes
and the memes and the documentaries
um but this is nice and I think like a
huge uh
part of this whole Saga was really how
terrible it was for the locals and the
natives and the restaurants and and all
the people showing up and that's really
to me like yeah the people who bought
tickets and didn't get what they wanted
and were like stranded that's bad too
but like
the people who live there and work there
and are trying to make a living and have
their home be infiltrated by a bunch of
like influencers like that was a huge
tragedy as well and so I appreciate that
that they're not being forgotten
honestly I do I have respect for this I
do also he's already working on another
Festival but it will be based in virtual
reality this time it's called pyrt
is that like party like I don't know I
think it's like similar to fire where
it's like the only vowel is a y and it's
not even a vowel oh right that was
probably where they went wrong most with
fire Festival spelling it with a y yeah
that's how you knew it was going down so
this is pert
um I definitely won't be at that one
because I don't do virtual reality
that's just like where I draw the line I
actually recently found out that
somebody I know like Loosely went to
fire Festival
and was a part of like the class action
lawsuit and like this person I don't
really know them that well but they like
refuse to talk about it it's like
illegal because they like got something
I want to know
at who
I'm not gonna say I know but like give
me a clue influencer layperson high
school friends I'm not gonna say I'm not
gonna oh I'll tell you after because
they're like really weird about it
interesting I mean I'd be weird about
two I'd be embarrassed yeah yeah yeah I
got conned
unless yeah unless they could parlay
that into like documentary Fame and
followers right like a few of the
influencers who like went all in and
they actually had like a good experience
like Helen Owen you know did she go I
believe so that's so embarrassing I
don't know if she was in the documentary
I just feel like I remember seeing
are there
but and they had like they actually got
a villa and it was fine
that's why people hate influencers like
Eat the Rich like oh I'm hearing my
villa I'm fine yeah but like the whole
everyone who went to the festival yeah
like it was an expensive Festival there
like you know it's just kind of was you
roll the dice as to who actually got a
house and who got a tent and who got a
cheese sandwich
that was such a crazy time like when it
was all happening in real time before
the documentary came out like yeah
that's crazy that was crazy
anyways those are the fast Side Stories
feel as though you needed to know them
I am so hungry what are you gonna have
for lunch such a great question turdy
Lou
you know when your stomach is so empty
and like it's making that sound all the
way like the sound travels like from
your belly to your butt you know that
sound yeah it's not a fart but I did
just order groceries they should be here
imminently but did it is there anything
oh I mean I could I got some eggs so
I've kind of been wanting to make like
you're gonna vomit to maybe take your
headphones off some like hard-boiled
eggs and like make that into like an egg
salad sandwich I actually like
hard-boiled eggs but you lost me at egg
salad no but I'm not gonna put anything
I'm just gonna be like mashed up
hard-boiled eggs with a little
close your ears uh gray Poupon
and so I'm not grossed out by that like
I know I would never eat it but like I
respect it but no it won't be actual egg
salad I don't like I don't want May or
anything I just like eggs oh and mustard
and bread so I put it together so it's
weird that's not like a normal thing
people eat I don't think that's weird
but then it also reminds me like I eat
very poorly and like I have a really
limited palette um in terms of like
things that I like it's very immature
but weirdly like ever since I was a kid
like something I really like there's
like a few things like I eat that people
are always shocked to find yeah like
cottage cheese I also really like a
hard-boiled egg without the yellow with
like a little Fleck of salt I think
that's like a nice snack and it's like
that's so toxic diet culture but like I
actually like it yeah no it is good if
and you wouldn't do this like a little
Laughing Cow Cheese on the inside a
little caviar oh I can't have caviar
right now but um
or I'm also gonna make some egg bites
because Harry and I tore through the egg
bites I made last weekend so I got more
I got a bunch of eggs so I'm gonna do
egg salad wow in this climate aren't you
rich over here I splurge because I don't
really have a lot of other protein
sources right right it's hard yeah
that's true I forgot about that well now
with your affiliate link you should be
able to get all the eggs you want we
shall see turd will start sending Zillow
links later literally
um well that's our show first one in a
while that's under an hour so no how
long are we at like 50
no I don't got another 10 minutes of
things to say a few minutes away of
course I would pontificate about
something pontificate what does that
mean to go on and on and it was a word
that was used a few times in this
episode of the redheads and snitch said
what does that mean and we said to go on
and on I actually learned a new word
from this dumb book that I read um and
it's a word that I had heard because
it's in the song illicit Affairs by
Taylor Swift Mercurial and then it was
in the book I'm like let me find out
what the [__] this [__] means you know
it means unpredictable great word a
dwindling Mercurial High add it to the
list
Mercurial I would like to start I feel
like my lunch is going to be a little
Mercurial honestly yeah no I feel like
my day is going to be like a little
Mercurial turdy Lou Who
um okay that's our show thank you guys
so much for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found on Spotify iTunes digital
public radio ayurvedic guest box all the
places so if you're listening to podcast
find us a toasty for five star review
about a beautiful standing in wicked
talented we are hope you guys have any
kayab Thursday we'll see you tomorrow
for Friday yay so exciting love you bye